[Music]
hi
buddy
[Music]
i know it's cold i know i know yeah can
you give me your thing
i know baby come here i
know baby come here come here
come here come here honey bear
will you give her the plate i haven't
given her the plate
i know
[Applause]
so
i know what are you doing
i know it's cold i know i'm not
i know it's cold i know i know
are you guys able to like make an
announcement to see if we can get the
owner to come out
next one
[Applause]
[Music]
mmm
[Applause]
i poured cold water all over me whenever
i got here
whenever i got here he was i poured he's
got cold water all over him from me
pouring this water bottle on him trying
to cool him down but
if we could check his garcia we'll take
it we got an ambulance
and he's you can tell he's still like
his body's really hot but i've poured
cold water all down his neck so he's
soaked
but his his legs and stuff are really
hot how long he was in there
i have no idea somebody caught out of
the car next to the truck and heard him
screaming